vivir esperando a quedarse sin hogar de
un momento a otro Esa es la situación
que padecen decenas de miles de
estadounidenses quienes después de que
aspiraran las normativas impuestas en la
pandemia quedan a Merced de las
inmobiliarias es el caso de Lane
Caroline una residente de Virginia que
debió abandonar su trabajo de
transportista por sufrir la enfermedad
de graves y se atrasó con los pagos del
alquiler a finales de 2022
cuando estaba en el hospital Los llamé y
me dijeron no ha habido pago este mes
Así que vamos a continuar con el proceso
de desalojo
es uno de los 96.000 casos que se han
registrado en enero de este año una
cifra ampliamente superior a los 6.600
que hubo en abril de 2020 en momentos de
pandemia según registro de visión lab
Los afectados entran en desesperación y
se ven obligados a buscar alternativas
realmente no tengo a dónde ir así que
estamos buscando Un refugio para
personas sin hogar y solo hay Un refugio
para solteros
expertos judiciales
en la situación y remarcan que el tiempo
entre la falta de pago y el desalojo es
de solo semanas
eso es realmente muestra con precaria es
la vida de muchas familias porque
realmente son de chequen chequen y puede
perder un cheque de pago no poder pagar
el monto total del alquiler y aún así
encontrarse en la corte en unas semanas
potencialmente desalojados dentro de una
semana o dos después de eso
horner recalcó que los valores de
vivienda son mucho más altos que en 2020
un aspecto que junto a la ausencia de
asistencia y la creciente inflación
hacen que pagar un alquiler sea una
misión difícil para miles de personas